para se vacunar sí o no es el proyecto
de ley que discute este lunes la
asamblea nacional de francia el gobierno
de manuel macro pretende pasar del pase
sanitario vigente que se obtiene si la
persona ha tenido como 19 o se ha
vacunado a un pase vacunal que niega la
entrada a espacios públicos a las
personas en la pauta completa de
vacunación todo ante el aumento
exponencial de contagios en las últimas
semanas debido a la variante omicron
luego además de con claudia da el
maremoto está aquí y ahora es
vertiginoso pero no vamos a ceder al
pánico el texto que vamos a exterminar
juntos es un texto de cabeza fría es un
texto de responsabilidad verán ha
acusado además de egoístas a quienes
según en la bandera en un falso discurso
de libertad para no vacunarse el bogotá
dijo hans schips esgrimen grandes
principios reivindican la libertad pero
su lucha es minúscula y desprecia
profundamente los principios elementales
para vivir juntos para vivir como
sociedad junto a las restricciones el
texto propone también mayores sanciones
para quienes compartan o falsifiquen sus
pases vacunales la extrema derecha pero
también la izquierda de la francia
insumisa lo rechazan alegando
restricción de libertades e ineficacia
de la mitosis haber apostado toda la
vacunación y no haber hecho nada más
demuestra que es una estrategia ineficaz
con respecto al cómic 19 así que es hora
de hacer las cosas de otra manera y
detener la brutalidad del pasivo vacunal
ropas beck sinaloa el gobierno espera
que el texto salga aprobado con el voto
a favor de la mayoría de conservadores y
de los socialistas de ser así el pase
vacunal entraría en vigor el próximo 15
de enero este mismo lunes en francia se
endurecieron las restricciones para
hacer frente a omicron habrá más
teletrabajo porte de mascarilla en
colegios para niños mayores de 6 años y
restricciones de aforo en lugares de
ocio